but i actually that's uh the way i  prefer the to write  and this is  my little this is my little trick that  none of you will want to do  uh  i will write a draft and then i'll put  it away for a year or so and then  uh or even two years or even three years  and then i'll come back to it and i'll  read it and i go who wrote it  and then i will read it like maybe two  or three times and then i will  throw that away and then rewrite it from  page one based on the memory of how of  what i read  and then my 120 page script will  suddenly be 80 pages um and it'll just  be the bare bones and just like the  the  yeah the important parts or the members  of the things like  remember from reading the script and so  i think there's a that's like quite a  good filter  system and then when you have like this  very sort of bare bones short version of  your story then you can add back in some  tonal stuff